in the previous episode and the epic
story continues
we are ready gonna hit the red button
you got 28 seconds somebody for a sec oh
oh
farm yo is that that's that's fun Oh
what about this
I got does not have a ceiling what is
that they loan so slow for me I can see
[ __ ] yeah I kinda like the one with the
toe in it okay we can go right now
what you didn't see the toe not in
theaters wedding
it was a toe in there it was like is
there a toe in there
I can't might know we're gonna refresh
it then yeah cuz you're on that tub yeah
we show it on here Oh what the hell is
that I don't know what oh there's no
tone that ones we don't want that
swanny looked oh are we talking about
here I think there might be a Tony
there's a toe in one of these maps
alright what is the toe do I don't get
lazy bug in the middle there ladybug
it's right in the middle at the beetle
yeah
reading the middle of the map it's a
beetle oh oh I get it
there's a snake no brain there's a brain
on the top right oh it's green one it's
disgusting
yes um first lunch it's our last chance
to of redemption here right gopher
Christ don't worry don't worry don't do
it
I'll kill one boy
wait oh boy oh wait I hate this it's
right it's right he did tomorrow damage
there hey I should know is that it what
what are you
why do you plot thing crying are you
still in the study so you think
definitely red dot over there whoa oh hi
hey there delicious Street Fighter no
you like it now pop-tarts brain next to
Danny Phantom yeah it was gonna go down
have you seen my show yeah where was
canceled like a couple years ago okay so
let me try to let me try this and and
and okay really yeah it's might take a
little bit to get over there hey I don't
go for all you didn't I take a little
bit
damnit ain't halls was there the whole
time I what was he doing there the whole
time
hey pressing ship it'll go a little
faster that frog in the background he's
watching us
I want to try to jump up there and see
if I can get up here what do you what's
happening with the ground oh I'm trying
to get over there nine seconds god damn
it that was really good
good job I just wanted to get up there
you can't say that I mean ice like true
but that's that guy hey you know talk
about how you that cry be on my team
they'll never get the chance to do
anything what do you want what do you
want me to do with you back home I'll
write like that for a little bit I don't
want to be hickey goodbye I want it be
pleasure Taco Bell that's all I wanted
to do what do I do
Oh find a my son of my demise I know
what this you've gonna fall straight
down whoa thank you guys to be together
yeah nice guys right there connected you
guys good side Smith you can't you can't
just do anything all right
I'm just gosh I'm gonna put you with
your buds down there wait don't do it
yet don't the way it why well because
doing that that's me Wow wait you six
damage what's the hell oh there he goes
hey pleasure him and then go back to the
other guy no okay okay come on pleasure
the Taco Bell
are you Frank okay no three of my people
is that you all your spoon yes oh yeah
you better know hey hey what are you
doing kidding me Wow Wow Wow
you're evil in that I want have done it
that's called boggy B by the way I have
any like on the right side I mean no I
don't okay should I try to get up this
thing again I should put away Who am I
oh hey I got so much violation going are
you giving me flowers okay there's my
quiet I failed with the shotgun again my
favorite weapon I'm sorry
got it no do not I gotta kill you oh no
you're gonna Gustav I gotta get a kill
here for does this to me miss what do
you got to say what do you got two
seconds well I didn't do much hey
Gillian I did it
I'm happy yeah well why are you in last
what you're doing come on now I need a
better teammate remember Wow
whoa a little bit of rivalry going on in
the team I only came down there all
right Oh
show em how it's done I don't I you know
are you pickin here you told me oh do it
the way it won't get old leave off alone
we've seen what do you do need no an
anal recovery I was massaging him stop
using my anals as like trackpads come on
Oh flowers for me no not recording a
while ago
I didn't I man that ain't right penny
break a leg penny all right make you
proud our moments I'm here get snap
get snap what do you get snap [ __ ]
grid no he's sitting with Taco Bell I
don't imagine him you are told you have
35 seconds to be Taco Bell I don't want
to be Taco Bell Wow wanna pick a the
halls I'm gonna get out of here why is
it a safe area
no say that you're fine doesn't a safe
area look at that water that you've made
you idiot okay that's not gonna lie
oh [ __ ] oh it works sorry Rudy
my name is the dynamite how do I get
there in the best way just - it's
working great
I'm trying to make this jump yeah how
can I make this jump drop drop
don't jump jump that's a dangerous jump
to it oh you gotta press spacebar to
launch it then he had a moving with
arrow keys on now what is this god
you're so [ __ ] lucky [ __ ] yes
boot what Pop Tart
Pop Tart Poppa pig poop carton do Rudy
fine oh don't do Rudy change my press
space right click they got there yeah
let's face again
he's good I don't know take Rooney out
what do you mean what do you do
do I do that did I use a businessman or
something use whatever can you get both
of them with the bat right uh uh uh bye
everybody
yes